let's see what's going on with people in
the audience we're gonna go to the
phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's start
with our caller from the four four three
area code caller from four four three
who's this where you calling from
hey David Pakman my name is Eric I'm
calling from Baltimore Maryland I doing
better hey Eric good how are you good
good I was just calling about the whole
Russia thing I think really that it's
time for it's time to let go of this
whole Russia thing because even the
Democrats like the leadership in the
Democrat Party in Congress and Senate
has completely shifted from Russian
collusion to sorry
trucks gone by from Russian collusion to
obstruction of justice and I really do
think it's just time for the Democrats
to just move on and you know just try to
try to be trouble at the ballot box
instead of just trying to get them out
of office well listen Eric I mean I
think you're right that either way the
the fastest removal of Trump is going to
happen by voting them out in November of
2020 so it sounds like on that part you
and I both are on the same page I think
where I would not necessarily disagree
but maybe try to refocus your thinking
is that on the one hand people who are
running in 2020 need to run the best
campaigns possible we've all got to get
out and vote we've got to make sure that
there's not this lack of enthusiasm but
by the left that we're seeing in polls
which might hold down turn out but the
Moller report does says say there were
there is substantial evidence of
obstruction on the 14 different
obstructive acts that robert muller
analyzed the three requirements to meet
the legal definition of obstruction were
met in eight of those fourteen so I
think it would be wrong to say because
it's faster to beat Trump in November of
2020 we should ignore the obstruction
part I think our current elected
officials should deal with the
obstruction part and meanwhile we've got
to make sure to go out and vote in
November of 2020 well well I mean I kind
of see what you're saying there but it's
the whole rest of the whole Western
narrative I mean even you yourself
you've been pushing the whole Kay what
Donald Trump received help from the
Russians here and this and that but
there was no Russian to lose I mean I
know we still got away or you know
Mulla to techo fire is not gonna shed
light listen Eric I mean when you when
you I don't know why you're pulling me
into it I've said from you know find a
club 13 months ago where I said if
you're waiting for the reports to say
Trump personally colluded with Putin
you're waiting for something that's
never going to happen
that doesn't change the fact that the
Trump Tower meeting happened
Papadopoulos you know all of that stuff
took place what was what was misguided
if anyone was doing it was imagining
that the results of the Moller report
would be Trump personally colluded with
Putin anyone who was waiting for that
certainly was waiting for something that
made no sense but again that to me
doesn't change if Moeller says in the
report there's substantial evidence of
obstruction unless you believe Moeller
is lying that's a very serious thing
well well no even when you brought up
the Trump Tower meeting if you even NBC
News a minute that you can look this up
a google it or whatever you do I can't
remember the lady's name the Russian
lawyer lady who met she met with Glenn
Simpson I'm using GPS before and after
the Don jr. Trump Tower me okay that
that's well known documented news so it
was it seemed like more of like a setup
and then you brought in papa
hold on Eric and what know is what was a
setup who was setting who up to do what
they sent the Russian lawyer in to Trump
Tower to say okay we have information on
Hillary Clinton or whatever they being
and they say anyway
Glenn Simpson is the founder of using
GPS which was hired by Perkins Coie
which is a Democrat Party law okay so so
here's what you're asserting is that
offering dirt on Hillary to the Trump
campaign was a set up by Democrats to
see if well known documented knew okay
all right Eric called us and you're
going into an area that is a little bit
disconnected from from reality so I'm
gonna let you go but I really your hope
and and in sorting this out but you know
I think we can walk and chew gum at the
same time the obstruction needs to be
dealt with and we got to win in November
of 2020